foreign
[Music]
I'll begin at the beginning which for me
is
they died in 1991 so what how did you
kind of make this film now like what
made this timely how did you discover
them and when
um so we first met Cassie and Maurice
actually when Shane and I were finishing
up the last film that we made together
which actually was part of the film
independent edit lab so could not have
been done without film Independence
um that film's called the Sierra Lee
unseen and it tells the story of an
Icelandic woman who's a communication
experience of nature we wanted to open
the film with archival imagery of
erupting volcanoes in Iceland
um specifically archival because we
wanted it to feel kind of out of time
and kind of magical um in terms of
totally how home we wanted to establish
the film
if there's any other steps too if you
want to add anything but that's kind of
how your first first met them
we were in the process of making another
film that we were going to shoot in
Siberia and we were doing that in early
2020 and when we were able to do that we
we decided to Pivot to make fire of love
and one of the interesting things was
that in a moment when we were so
constrained and so unable to to see the
world and to travel and make films and
the way we we were accustomed to making
them it was a real sell for us during
the pandemic it's beautiful
um so where is the archive of all of
their incredible footage and was it easy
to get access to it's when we started
the project it was an American house
called image EST in LC France Maurice's
Brother Rich on Craft had actually
through the years it was difficult for
him to manage his archive that he
inherited and so he didn't trusted into
the various archival houses um and by
the time we came to it was uh
um it actually wasn't that hard to get
it took a few phone calls that were led
by our other producer Anna Fishman
um modest was wonderful to work with
eritron craft Maurice's brother liked
her approached him so he gave his
approval and consent for us to work with
himaches to receive the footage
um but there was another batch that was
about 200 hours I should say of uh of 16
millimeter footage that Captain Maurice
took along with thousands of still
photographs there was then another kind
of active footage that we worked with
outside of that archive and television
programs of documentaries that were made
of Katy and Maurice they were mostly on
kind of French TV Belgian TV there's
some radio your broadcasts as well those
were really fun for us to work with
because that's really the only time
content Maurice were together and
speaking because they were rarely
together in their own footage and she
also say their own footage came to us
without any sound so that kind of
tremendous complexity in the edit room
was here also did they all that radio
and TV stuff was that stuff they
compiled in their lives or did their
brother his brother do it or how did it
how did it all come to be in one place
so actually was collected through our
archival researcher Nancy Marcos who is
an amazing hero of our project she
poured through all kinds of archives
throughout Europe and also in the US to
collect them we had the great Fortune
also interviewing some of Captain
Reese's loved ones and collaborators and
so they had some personal archives
there's one cinematographer Olivier
zawat for example who shot with Maurice
and Katya for many years and he after
they died he made his own documentary
about Captain Maurice and he gave us a
VHS copy and we then you know
transferred uh to get to work with that
as well so that Nancy really LED that
process of archival research and yeah
she's definitely one of the heroes on
our team
all right there were a couple scenes
where it looked like they were shooting
on video did you also get was there kind
of a progression of film technology in
their Archive of different formats
looks like they mostly shot on 16
millimeter but that's do you want to
talk about coming across the footage
during the edit sure yeah um
the progression you mentioned definitely
we noticed that as we looked through the
the footage that they shot over the
years
um it was I think all 16 millimeter
um sometimes the video you might see in
the film is from programs ever made
about them
um so if
um there are a few shots every now and
then where they're out in the field and
it's a TV crew we're getting special
about the reason because aircraft
um and at times those shots were
indispensable in terms of oh there's a
shot of the two of them together so we
would integrate them
um but
um over the years it seemed like they
were evolving there's a their own style
always and there are differences I
noticed and if you track it more or less
I mean it was never 100 we didn't have
um 100 Clarity on the chronology of what
we were looking at
um we had to puzzle it together but
there were many reels of footage that
didn't have a mirror attached they're
actually very few heavier attached then
we had to infer by reading their books
and talking to all like all the
interviews Sarah conducted but
um yeah it seemed like the the filming
increasingly the camera would
um like would that I think the camera
lingers longer as they um
uh got older maybe at first it seemed
like the shooting style was um uh like
there were more snap zooms it was almost
like more directly influenced by the
French new wave and over the years maybe
um maybe it was more influenced by
Terminator or just I don't know but I
was always wondering what what kind of
reference what films were they
representing because I think there were
cinephiles it just seemed like they um
yeah that there's and we talked about
that a lot I think I feel like I'm
forgetting something about the how their
style progressed
um
Sarah
we talked about this before there was
something else yeah I I think you
captured it really well but they they
did seem to because that's more of a
confidence not just with their
cinematography and their photography but
also their relationship with volcanoes
um that progressed of course as
something we document in the film but we
always wondered if they had the sense
too that they could die at any moment
and so they were trying to shine
themselves in their own myth didn't I
um because they do show up a little bit
more as figures go on cocktail for
example that used for scale against
these you know enormous volcanic uh
Landscapes and yeah but that was
something we wondered if they knew that
they were setting their image their
story to posterity because they could
die at any at any moment so I'll just
say a lot of questions abounded as we
went through the process that it was
such a delight to get to see the
progression of their imagery through the
years right it's really interesting to
hear you all talk about the evolution of
their style as filmmakers and I I was
thinking about watching it but you were
getting to know them as
subjects in a sort of the thematics of
the film but also getting to know them
as fellow filmmakers and like I'm just
curious that like
for you
I mean did you feel like you were like
meeting a kindred spirit or was it
somebody with a filmmaking style totally
unlike your own or you're a more sort of
observing it or you know he's yeah
that's a great question I love that
question and I hope you all chime in but
um I think we've just loved them so much
I think I would dream to be a kindred
spirit with them
um I think one of the things that I wish
to move by was how their imagery
captured what felt like the sentence of
nature just the utter power aliveness
and interactivity of of of the earth of
you know lava of volcanic gas oh the
bubbling mud all of it there's such
relationships everywhere and they are
such a sense of a life force
um for me and my work that's something
I'm really drawn to is how humans make
meaning with um and out of non-human
nature and I just found that everywhere
and the way that they wrote about
volcanoes the way they shot volcanoes so
that was extremely exciting to get to
work with
um yeah what did you sign into
no no I think we all had a sense of
kinship with them as filmmakers but also
as deliverers of Life yeah here are
these people that were were trying
urgently to figure out how to live a
meaningful life and die on meaningful
that how to get closer to a sense of
understanding even if you can never
fully understand and I think for that
because of that they were they were
inspiring artists inspiring scientists
inspiring humans and and to get this
done the time that we did without this
real gift yeah beautiful I am
one of the things I love about this film
is what's not in it and you know you
don't cut away to contemporary Talking
Heads or a lot of conventions of more
you know boring uh documentary film and
I mean it's so alive it feels you know
just cinematically unbelievably rich and
exciting and Incredibly pleasurable to
watch too I mean there's just the you
know the I mean their footage of the
volcanoes and of nature as you were
talking about is like I could just I
could have watched another you know hour
of that
um but I'm curious if you could talk
about how you make decisions I mean your
previous work also doesn't you don't
seem to rely on the talking head
interview but like how did you decide to
structure this this way where it's
almost entirely their footage and then
with the the news footage inner cut
um we were fascinated by the idea of
kind of an archival project that almost
um or that had a kinship with geology or
geologic methodologies in a way of
taking kind of the clues that are left
behind from these people's lives um and
you know surveying them
um putting them in relationship with the
images in relationship with each other
but also acknowledging the Naps you know
they're they're the archive is
spectacular but also so limited they're
uh you know as I mentioned before the 16
millimeter fetish didn't have uh sound
to it
um the the news footage the the
intelligent broadcasts that they were on
um were often edited and uh very strange
ways to say the least so we were really
um limited with what we could do with it
but those gaps those limitations kind of
spread or just opened up new creative
possibilities but I think the one of the
most fascinating ones for us was just
embracing the unknowns all that we could
ever know because it wasn't captured in
the visual record
um and because it passed away and it
could ever verify the information no
matter how much research we did with the
people that they knew and we interviewed
or from their you know many books
um so it was really embracing kind of a
language of the unknown
um that we mentioned through our
narration
um and so we kind of hint at with the
scientific process of going towards you
know the vast mysteries of our had to
only to realize you can't understand uh
this seemingly Supernatural force and
the same thing too with the mysteries of
Love
um but I think that actually so the
unknown is a huge part to that
structured kind of our approach but it
really it always connects a love story
for us
um there was a sentence that we read in
a book that Maurice authored where he
says for me Katya volcanoes it is a love
story and with that we thought oh this
is our thesis you know it's a love
triangle it's about these two humans in
love with this this massive vast
unknowable force and that really was
kind of the key guide and helped us to
kind of structure The Narrative Arc of
the film and I think we also we sort of
believed in our project of of love and
Science and I think for us we recognize
that those things are best communicated
through story and story and oftentimes
best teaching you dated through men and
that they were involved in their own
with creation and for us too we wanted
to create something that was I was
reflective of the fact of their life I
was also bigger than their life and and
the touch approach some sort of Truth
and I think that required a very
different treatment than a talking head
with a talking head movie
you know that that juxtaposition of the
the theme of like you know the inherent
unknowability of nature or other people
combined with that
there's a sense of humor that comes
through in the film and I suspect it's
your sense of humor but also theirs
um and warmth and love is you know
there's the line is it um curiosity is
stronger than fear and that sort of
sentiment where it couples the
unknowability and the sort of
implacability of Nature and the
destructiveness of it with this just
like we're going about our business yeah
it's probably going to kill us but we're
going to keep doing this and I mean it's
a really striking juxtaposition that is
beautiful
I made a comment not a question sorry I
like it I love that
um that's something we actually talked a
lot about in the in the edit room
um this first thank you for that lovely
comment
we often um well first I should say
costume race were hilarious they were so
playful and they were so close with one
another
um that was something we wanted to
really Embrace and we worked so
collaboratively on on this film like
Aaron Aaron lives in New York but
basically moved in with me I live in the
Bay Area Jocelyn lives just up the hill
from me she was at my house all hours
team lives here in LA but I was also at
my house all the time so we really had
this like group mentality where we were
working long hours into the night and we
just laughed so much so Captain Reese
inspired a process and US of joy and it
was such an honor to get to play with
and interpret their footage so I hope
that kind of the poem that we had can be
felt in the film
um but I also think that uh there's
something about understanding the
absurdity of life in a way that they
knew so so probably
um they thought human interaction and
activity was often absurd and so that's
part of what drove them towards
volcanoes because they saw something
like
to where they could just laugh at
themselves yeah and I feel like those
those are conversations they often had
definitely it's just that they were
students of the financial related there
were also students of existentialism and
they were reading you know
UNESCO and and in spite of that is just
the most pain there's an absurdity to to
those works and to existential
philosophy and also to life when you're
when you're immersed in that and if you
if you really embody the spirit of it
you're going to be playful you're going
to see meaning and and intentionality
and fundamental truths I also going to
see a certainty
so I love the image of the four of you
working on this film laughing
um at your house but I would love to
hear you talk more about the writing of
this because and I mean the whole yeah
how did you write this uh I'm talking
about specifically the written words
that Miranda delivers but I mean it's so
beautifully written it feels like
incredible fiction you know that the
voice
um right it's not a again it's not a
conventional narration of facts or
anything but how did you could you talk
about finding that voice and also just
how four people construct that together
I can't imagine sure yeah I'll kick it
off but please Johnson and and Shane
Wayne
um we at the very beginning we did not
want a narrator I really hoped that it
would just kind of feel their footage
but due to all the limitations and do
the due to the fact that we really
wanted this to be a love story again
because that seemed to be what was the
most true to them even though you can of
course interpret their footage in many
ways if we were to do a character-driven
love story we needed another narrative
device in order to bring that
information in and so we decided also
inspired by the French new way that
employees really interesting modes of
narration to go about writing narration
of our own however we didn't want it at
all to feel like a voice of God narrator
if we wanted
um a voice I was curious and perhaps as
inquisitive as patient Maurice
um so that kind of set forth the
beginnings of uh yeah the style
um I'll leave it there and to let my
collaborators take take over who wants
to check them I think I think a lot of
it was led let by Sarah where there
would be ideas with you know we would be
watching the footage and have ideas
about different sections that we wanted
to we knew we wanted to integrate into
the film but not sure how it was tied
together and
um Sarah Jocelyn and Aaron were on a
slack channel that was just ding
constantly and every hour of the night
every day of the week
um with ideas and and and just like
meditating for for hours on if it should
be you know the or a
um
but having a real sense of the four of
us knowing how there was no no sense of
ego in any of it it was just we were
fine but doesn't wanted to say and when
you when you hear what the film wants to
say like oh yeah that's it and it's just
a process of not really even writing and
sort of uncovering what what wants to be
said
um and I think there was a there you
know Jocelyn um
necessary it's quiet to me but she was
like she was our um she was our first
narrator actually and did an amazing job
that was the lead the foundation for
Miranda to come in and even in the even
when we're recording with Miranda you
know we were we were tweeting lines and
words to the very end and Miranda
oftentimes like the thousands of like
this doesn't say that correctly is that
the intention of the writing of that
moment
um and yeah and it was uh I think it's
hard you know coming with a cohesive
voice with with poor people that seemed
relatively relatively smooth in this
case
I'll just add that um
got to know
her overtime and developed rules over
time around what she would and wouldn't
say
um at first there was more Exposition
and that was simply a result of
narrative scaffolding that we needed at
first to put the story together and then
you know over time we were able to lose
lines as other elements of the film came
together and as the structure
crystallized and that's one of my
favorite parts of the process is when
you can start losing
narration especially or text I guess we
didn't have text on the screen really so
narration and
um but I do remember specifically just
having yeah very long like threads or
conversations around how the narrator
would know this and which which you know
this or maybe over time I just I think
if you could do a time lapse of the text
of the narration you would over time see
more question marks in the entirety of
the text at first it was a little more
declarative but then we found our
footing and embrace this inquisitive
character and that really yeah we never
pictured who the narrator is or oh that
was one rule that we developed is that
the narrator never said I or referring
to the sort of embodied
human behind the voice there was never
any reference to um yeah we didn't want
to call attention to the world of the
narrator but that was not clear at Birth
it was rules that we developed over time
among other yeah
so related to that I also wanted to ask
about the music and the film which I
thought was fantastic put up the score
and that and those kind of songs that he
is I mean the French uh tour I
the kind of torch song early early on is
it not normal or I don't know the name
of the song but it's like an incredible
moment if it was just the music works so
well there
um can you talk about sort of
the process of putting music into this
and how that related to the narration
and
just building that sure well we very
much
see all these discrete elements to kind
of build this this whole um and music
was one of those textures that we were
so excited to play with
um again there's no imagery at the
Emery's sitting or holding hands going
on dates like conventional imagery of a
love story so we really saw music as a
way to bring in emotion and kind of
speak to The Whimsy and the power of
falling in love
um we always kind of dreamed of what we
called a retro futuristic score or
another way of putting it is like
dreaming of the future but from a
perspective of the past we thought that
that just hit them especially some of
their kind of their fun kind of sci-fi B
movies Aesthetics with a themselves and
race that would just be fitting and so
we started brainstorming
um you know musicians who we liked who
could fit that or do that well and air
came to mind the French pop band and
Nico Nikolai our composer is one half of
of heir of the duo air
um he was wonderful to work with but we
also had a lot of fun kind of playing
with music in the edits especially to
bring some scenes together
um yeah that didn't have sound so I'll
kind of pass the Baton over to you guys
I talk about your abusive of music and
edit yeah I think probably my favorite
part of the edit would be the musical
Dimension
um I think it just made sense right off
the bat for me Maurice and how dare to
me are very musical humans and so are
volcanoes
and um it just kept it either
I had a hard time not having music and
if anything I had to get done with that
I look back and not put music everywhere
but there was just um
it especially where um our the footage
the archive is silent it was another way
to kind of explore the Sonic World of
the archive in the more subjective way
um rather than do the the sound design
of the volcano what if we
embrace the musicality of it and um
also a love story component
um it is a way to express the love like
Sarah said there's no shots of them
holding hands or or kissing or anything
but every you know being able to throw
in a few a few very romantic music cues
is another way to just
um
tell that love story so I have a great
time for the music yeah
which is just it it also just brings us
back to the writing conversation too
because you know as Sarah was saying we
thought of this as a collage film and
when you add music the music
communicates something and I love it and
I'll put all the filmmakers too you know
the music that's something that you were
previously saying about narration and
then you see the music and you realize
that you don't have to say that with the
narration that you want because the
music is probably not part of the story
so there's also this really beautiful
conversation that happens between music
sound picture word text and and um you
know and it's interesting because the
music generally interests you know
Nico's music came in later and then that
made us have to readjust you know
oftentimes what we were going to say or
what we're going to see on screen and
then go back to the music into the music
actually has to account for this because
we know we have to say this and music
can't say it so it's a it's a beautiful
conversation that happens
Shane I wanted to ask you a question as
as producer what were the biggest
challenges with producers as a producer
what were the biggest challenges in
producing this type of film where it's
all it's archival you're not you have a
lot of locations or you know physical
production going on but what what were
the challenges for you as a producer
I mean I think the the team you know
made it made a relatively easy and just
ones there are incredible to work with
and I know we had like a we had a lot of
and you know we had somebody we see our
animator like the I think the hardest
part usually in making a film is
wrangling wrangling a team and making
sure that everyone works well together
and doing what they need to do and in
this project that was that was largely
largely on track but um you know with
great with problems with the general
challenges that happen in any production
but I think more than anything and this
film is is
um slightly different in the sense that
we knew we had when we saw their footage
and when we heard their story we knew
that this was something truly special
profound and I think the hardest thing
when you look at that is is doing honor
to Maurice and doing honor to the
possibility of a film that can really
really touch touch people's heart
you see it has a chance I think that's
the hardest thing you know to make sure
that you live up to the possibility of
of the subjects and of the footage yeah
um I think we have time for one more
question I'm being given the the gesture
um so but my last question is
um
so this film has come out in the world
uh hopefully on the other side of the
pandemic or audiences are able to see
this in theaters this has not been a
virtual release and it's it had such an
impact on audiences and I'm curious what
your experience of that has been have
you watched it with audiences have you
been able to see how it's affecting
people I'm curious your reaction to how
the film is impacting audiences and what
you're hearing back
well it's been a tremendous honor to
have the film out in the world
um National Geographic films in neon
however that have been our theatrical
Partners
um in putting people out into the world
and working with them it's really been a
dream
um on on one note just kind of
referencing what Shane just said the
fact that Katie and Maurice you know 30
years ago they were touring the world
showing these images to people in their
presentations and conferences that they
gave the fact that their images are torn
to the world again it just means so much
um and on that note I actually I I have
trouble watching the film because I
still like well thank goodness but
um the first time I watched it since we
had kind of a friends and family
screaming um during the Sundance
Premiere which technically went virtual
this year but we kind of we gathered
with some friends to watch it
um the second time I actually watched it
was in France after the French Premiere
where Maurice's brother Gershon gave the
introduction and I was so meaningful
like I choked up thinking about it
um and it was actually at the Louvre
which was really exciting for us for
these scientists to have their work be
celebrated as art so that was incredible
to see it with a French audience many of
their loved ones
um people consulted on the film
um and people we didn't even know but
they had touched as cartoon research
touched their lives came up to us
afterwards and so um that was just
particularly profound but it's been
really wonderful to hear people connect
to the film
I went to start one one thing our one of
our executive producers jessara was just
in on that on a trip and she reported
back that she was wearing a fire of Love
button on her back and someone came up
to her and said we just saw Fire Emblem
this is in Italy we just saw fire of
love in the theaters and like we decided
to come to Montana because of the
facility and it was like it was this
couple
um who had done it together and so for
us that's just that's extraordinary
that's great a movie inspired
um two people two lovers to like be in
love with each other and go be in nature
and experience a volcano the creator of
the world and you know this is
Romantics for us it was that was a dream
come true that the movie could
participate in in changing more
civilized and changing and affecting the
world in that way
[Music]
um and I'll just add that it's also just
a delight with um with live audiences
um to uh see people jump back in their
seats when there's an explosion or laugh
um when something we were editing in
such a bubble and sometimes I think like
any editing process gets very you can
get very um insular they just it just
becomes like that and we had a few test
screenings throughout the process but
it's a big difference from a small test
screening to large audiences and so it
was there's been also just from the
editing's endpoint just reassurance
um and relief at people laughing at the
things that we were hoping we would
laugh at and
um
that's just delightful
to to have that shared experience that's
something that we we loved putting
together we joked a little bit that it
was like we were when we were working at
Sarah's house it was like working on an
art project and
um never dreamed really that it would
end up reaching so many people so and
that's
yeah yeah very um
gratifying
well Sarah Shane Jocelyn thank you so
much for being here tonight thank you
for this beautiful film
February
[Music]